do you think we're going to be okay
as a human civilization he said
absolutely we don't know
absolutely do you think it's do you
think we'll
prosper or destroy ourselves as
in general in general i'm an optimist
the no i think that the you know it'll
be interesting to see for example with
this
you know pandemic i you know to me
you know when you look at like
organizations for example
you know having some kind of
perturbation some kick to the system
usually the end result of that is
actually quite good
you know unless it kills the system it's
actually quite good usually
and i think in this case you know people
i mean my impression
you know it's a little weird for me
because you know i've been a remote
tech ceo for 30 years it doesn't you
know this is bizarrely
uh you know in the fact that you know
like this coming to see you here is
is the best time in six months
that i've been like you know in a
building other than my house
okay so so so you know it's i'm i'm a
kind of
ridiculous outlier in these kinds of
things but overall your senses
when you shake up the system and throw
in chaos that you
you uh challenge the system we humans
emerge
better seems to be that way who's to
know but i think that
you know people you know my sort of
vague impression is that people are sort
of
you know oh what's actually important
you know what's
uh what what is worth caring about and
so on and that seems to be something
that
perhaps is is more you know emergent in
this kind of situation
it's so fascinating that on the
individual level
we have our own complex cognition we
have consciousness we have intelligence
we're trying to figure out little
puzzles
and then that somehow creates this graph
of collective intelligence
where we figure out and then you throw
in these viruses
of which there's millions different you
know this entire taxonomy
and the viruses are thrown into the
system of collective human intelligence
and when little humans figure out what
to do about it we get like we tweet
stuff
about information there's doctors
there's conspiracy theorists
and then we play with different
information i mean the whole of it is
fascinating
uh i i am like you also very optimistic
but uh
there's a fee just you said uh the
computational reducibility
there's always a fear of the darkness of
the uncertainty
be before us yeah it's scary
i mean the thing is if you knew
everything it would be boring
and yeah and it would be and and then um
uh
and worse than boring so to speak it
would be you it would reveal the
pointlessness so to speak
and in a sense the the fact that there
is this computational irreducibility
it's like as we live our lives so to
speak
something is being achieved we're
computing what our lives
you know uh you know what happens in our
lives
that's fine so the computational
disability is kind of like
it gives the meaning to life it is the
meaning of life computation reducibility
is the meaning of life
there you go it gives it meaning yes i
mean it it it
it's what it's what causes it to not be
something where you can just say
uh you know you went through all those
steps to live your life but
we already knew what the answer was
you